THIS INVESTIGATION CLEARLY
CONTINUING.
AND JOINING ME WITH MUCH MORE I;
a
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION HANDLE;
ENTITIES NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW;
a
BUT AS YOU ARE STANDING THERE ;
ACROSS, WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHTS OF
THE MOTIVATIONS OF THIS PERSON?;
a
AND LIKE YOU SAID, IT IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION, SO I DON'T WANT
TO GET AHEAD OF WHERE THEY ARE
IN TERMS OF THE MOTIVE WAS HERE;
a
AND THE ACTUAL INTENT.
CLEARLY THIS INDIVIDUAL INTENDED
SOME KIND OF HARM BY RAMMING THE
TRUCK THROUGH THE PYLONS, AND ;
a
BUT I DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
WHERE THE INVESTIGATION IS. ;
a
OR THE FIRST LADY WERE IN ANY ;
DANGER LAST NIGHT?
>> I HAVE TO TAKE THE WORD OF ;
a
IT CLEAR THAT THEY WERE NOT. ;
THEY TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITIES ;
a
INCREDIBLY SERIOUSLY, AND IT IS;
LAFAYETTE SQUARE IS JUST OVER MY
SHOULDER WHERE THIS OCCURRED AN;
a
PROPERTY.
SO AGAIN, WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND
THE PARK SERVICE, AND THE SECRE;
a
SERVICE FOR THE VERY, VERY ;
PROMPT ACTION THAT THEY TOOK ;
a
THEMSELVES, THEY HAVE SAID THAT
AT NO TIME WAS THE PRESIDENT OR;
a
THE FIRST LADY IN ANY DANGER. ;
>> THEY DID.
>> AND ALSO, JOHN, I WANTED TO ;
a
ASK YOU ABOUT EVAN GERSHKOVICH,;
AND HE IS IN COURT TO APPEAL HIS
PRETRIAL CONVICTION AND BEFORE ;
a
DETENTION FOR ANOTHER THREE
MONTH, AND WE KNEE THE SFB HAD ;
a
BEEN ASKING FOR THAT AND HE HAD
ASKED FOR A HOUSE ARREST IN THE;
a
YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT.
>> I AM JUST HEARING THAT NEWS
FOR FIRST TIME HERE, AND I DON';
a
SHOULD NOT BE HELD AT ALL, AND
HE SHOULD BE RELEASED
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
VIEW, AND PRESIDENT BIDEN'S ;
a
CERTAINLY NOT EXTENDED.
I AM JUST COMING INTO THE NEWS ;
a
HEARING IT FROM YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND EVEN BEFORE THIS, I WAS
GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT HIS ;
a
>> THIS IS THE SECOND TIME THAT;
BASIC AND I WOULD SAY REQUIRED,
BUT THEY ARE BREAKING ALL KINDS;
a
INTERNATIONAL LAW, BUT IT IS AN;
OBLIGATION FOR THEM TO ALLOW THE
CONSULAR VISITS AND WHY ARE THE;
a
?
>> WE WANT THAT ACCESS, AND WE
WANT TO TALK TO HIM DIRECTLY AND
CHECK IN ON HIM AND SEE HOW HE ;
a
NOT CLEAR WHY THEY ARE DENYING ;
IT, AND MAYBE IT IS SPITEFULNESS
OVER THE ANTIPATHY OF THE UNITED
STATES OR THE FREE PRESS OR SOM;
a
IS NO GROUNDS TO DENY CONSULAR ;
ACCESS.
IT IS WRONG TO DETAIN AMERICANS;
a
AROUND THE WORLD, AND WE WANT TO
GET THAT CONSULAR ACCESS GOING.;
a
>> JOHN, I WANTED TO SPEAKING O;
RUSSIA IS SAYING THAT THE FORCE;
a
CALLING THE UKRAINIAN FORCES ;
ANTI-PUTIN NATIONALS FIGHTING ;
a
>> WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A WHOLE
LOT OINFORMATION ON THE ATTACKER
HOO, KATE.
IT DOES APPEAR IT IS RUSSIAN ;
a
SYMPATHIZING GROUPS, IF YOU ;
WILL, THAT SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
WAR IN UKRAINE, BUT RUSSIAN ;
a
ORIGIN MAKING THE ALLEGED ;
ATTACKS HERE IN AND AROUND
BELGRADE AND HOW THEY CARRIED ;
a
OUT THE ATTACKS.
WHEN IT IS COMING TO THESE ;
a
ATTACKS, WE ARE NOT HELPING OR ;
SUPPORTING THESE ATTACKS, ;
a
BECAUSE IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING;
THAT UKRAINE CAN ATTACK AND
DEFEND THEIR OWN TERRITORY.
>> AND NOW, WE ARE LEARNING THA;
a
BE PROVIDED, AND IS THERE A ;
PROCESS TO WHERE THE UNITED
STATES WOULD PROVIDE F-16s, AND
WHY WOULDN'T YOU?
IF YOU NOW SUPPORT THIS MOVE, ;
a
AND ANY GOOD REASON NOT TO?
>> I WILL TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
WORKING OUR WAY THROUGH THAT, ;
a
THE PRESIDENT DID ANNOUNCE THAT
WE WILL START TO PROVIDE ;
a
TRAINING FOR THE UKRAINIAN
PILOTS TO LIKELY OCCUR IN EUROP;
a
NOT FAR FROM UKRAINE, SO MANY
TRAINING EVENTS THAT WE HAVE ;
a
ALREADY DONE FOR MANY UKRAINIAN
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN IN EUROPE,;
a
COUNTRY, AND ALL OF THAT HAS TO;
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE LAID OUT THIS;
a
NEW TRAINING COMMITMENT, IT WAS
TO ALSO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE ;
a
WILL BE WORKING WITH A COALITIO;
WITH THE ADVANCED FIGHTER ;
a
AIRCRAFT TO WORK OUT THE DETAILS
OF THAT.
I CAN'T SAY YES OR NO RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE WE ARE BEGINNING THE
PROCESS, BECAUSE WE WILL SEE HOW
IT FLUSHES OUT.
BUT THE MAIN THING, THEY W